disgraced Hollywood mogul Harvey
Weinstein faces new criminal charges in
Los Angeles as jury selection gets
underway today for his trial in New York
the Los Angeles District Attorney's
Office announced yesterday Weinstein has
been charged with raping one woman and
sexually assaulting another in 2013
Jericka Duncan is outside the courthouse
in New York where Weinstein appeared for
a pre-trial hearing yesterday Jericka
what do we know about these new charges
good morning Anthony what we're learning
is that Harvey Weinstein is likely to be
arraigned in Los Angeles after the trial
wraps up here in New York prosecutors in
LA are recommending that bail be set at
five million dollars now we do know that
several women came forward in Los
Angeles about allegations of sexual
assault by Harvey Weinstein and while
two of those cases have resulted in
those new charges that we're talking
about prosecutors say there are still
other cases under investigation we
believe the evidence will show that the
defendant used his power and influence
to gain access to his victims and then
committed violent crimes against them in
Los Angeles County Monday District
Attorney Jackie lacy announced new
criminal charges against Harvey
Weinstein including forcible rape and
sexual battery by restraint to those
victims I want you to know we see you we
hear you and we believe you according to
the DA's office On February 18 2013
Weinstein allegedly raped a woman in a
Los Angeles hotel room the next evening
he allegedly sexually assaulted a
different woman in a hotel suite in
Beverly Hills it was just days before
his film Django Unchained won two
Academy Awards
Weinstein appeared in court in New York
Monday hunched over and leaning on a
walker the 67 year old is on trial there
for allegedly sexually assaulting two
women one in 2006 and the other in 2013
his attorneys say they're concerned
about a fair trial we're going to
continue to press on and remind everyone
that in this great country you are
innocent until proven guilty meanwhile
attorney Douglas wig door says his
client a Weinstein accuser will soon
tell her story publicly for the first
time her allegations are not part of the
charges Weinstein is facing in New York
but her testimony could help paint a
picture of Weinstein's alleged behavior
she will support the main two victims by
showing Harvey Weinstein's modus
operandi in 2005 wig door says his
client was sexually assaulted by
Weinstein and the film producers New
York City apartment she was working as a
waitress when Weinstein allegedly
expressed interest in her career the me2
movement has really changed things but
it is the right thing to hold Harvey
Weinstein and people like Harvey
Weinstein accountable outside the
courthouse Monday dozens of protesters
including several Weinstein accusers
gathered to echo that sentiment
you thought you could terrorize me and
others into silence you were wrong
Weinstein's defense team asked the judge
to sequester the jury but the judge
denied that request now Harvey Weinstein
has pleaded not guilty to the charges
he's facing here in New York and has
said all along that he denies all
allegations of non-consensual sex but if
he is convicted whether in Los Angeles
or in New York he is facing the rest of
his life behind bars Tony
jurika thank you very much
you